at 605 this morning a grieving mom is
thanking the woman who helped her
younger son
after he watched his brother get hit and
killed by a car 8 news now reporter
victoria saha has the emotional reunion
in a story that you'll only see here on
8 news now
i see you on the news and i said oh my
god i just want to meet her i just want
to tell her thank you that was
somebody's baby
a raw moment shared between a grieving
mom and a witness to a horrible accident
that took 15 year old keith young's life
desiree andreessen was at the stoplight
when keith and his younger brother
daniel were crossing when they weren't
supposed to daniel made it to the other
side of the street but a driver hit
keith and fled and he's just grabbing
him from behind and pulling him out of
traffic so he doesn't get hurt anymore
andreessen stayed by daniel to shield
him from the horror you were a mom at
that moment and you kicked it in the
gear in the absence in my you stood in
my absence the family is remembering
keith as a young boy who loved video
games and lit up every room as they
process the tragic accident keith's
father has some words for the driver who
hit his son
you murdered
a child how can you live knowing that
you have taken a life
and did not even think
to stop and see did not even think to
care and see was that person was all
right keith would have turned 16 years
old on sunday victoria saha 8 news now
that crash had happened friday night
near sierra vista high school and police
are still looking for the suspect that
person driving a later model red dodge
charger the left mirror is missing may
have some windshield damage if any
information please call police or
remember you can call crime stoppers and
remain anonymous
it is now 607